what's popping Sky guys it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
Hayden Christensen is finally back doing
the lightsaber spinnies and glorious 4K
all while teaching his former Padawan
Ahsoka a lesson from beyond the grave
but what exactly was that lesson and how
did ahsoka's Journey Through the past
give her a key piece of knowledge that
will help her in the future let's dive
into it all together my nerd baby
padawans all right so basically the main
lesson that Anakin was trying to teach
Ahsoka was to stop being afraid of the
mark that he left on her because that
fear has been causing Ahsoka to doubt
herself and become a less effective
Master to her Padawan and a far less
lethal Warrior on the battlefield and
this is sort of teased during ahsoka's
battle with Balin in episode 4 in order
to throw Ahsoka off of her game Balin
skull pretty much immediately locks in
on and pokes at ahsoka's biggest
insecurity by telling her that she was
nothing but another mistake of Anakin
Skywalker and that all of her actions
were destined to be linked to his dark
and destructive Legacy Ahsoka has always
carried this fear of being just another
weapon sharpened by the violent man who
would become the monster Darth Vader
because she fears that his past dark
influence has rubbed off on her and you
can sort of see that manifest in episode
4 when Ahsoka Force slammed Shin hati
against a rock when she assumed that
Shin killed Sabine that was an extremely
aggressive act rooted in Anger a type of
Darker aggression that Ahsoka has seen
Anakin justify at times during the Clone
Wars and she desperately wants to prove
that she is not anything like him
because you see Ahsoka was born into a
culture that had a deep respect for
nature and life if you watch tales of
the Jedi then you would know that the
very first episode of that series
details the birth and early baby days of
Ahsoka even before she had the ability
to speak ahsoka's mother was trying to
instill in her important lessons about
the circle of life and respecting all of
life and in that same episode we see a
baby Ahsoka be taken from her mother by
a wild saber-tooth animal only for that
saber-tooth to willingly and peacefully
bring Ahsoka back to her Village after
seeing that the baby Ahsoka was
strangely not afraid of the animal
threatening to kill her that saber-tooth
saw ahsoka's lack of fear for what she
didn't understand as something special
to be preserved because most babies and
beings would probably be balling their
eyes out in that situation but baby
Ahsoka was literally just laughing and
trying to connect with her new furry
friend it is because of this moment that
ahsoka's people realized that she was
destined to become a Jedi by the end of
the episode as Jedi were the greatest
protectors and respector of life in the
entire galaxy at the time and what was
the name of that first tales of the Jedi
episode life and death the same themes
involved in Anakin's Cosmic lesson to us
so in episode 5 of her show live or die
and this is why Anakin brings Ahsoka on
this journey through her past because
during that Journey we get to see the
emotional toll that wartime death takes
on a young Ahsoka who was born with a
massive innate sense of empathy for
every living being even the Clon
soldiers that the Senate and the
galactic Republic as a whole viewed as
Expendable tools that were made to die
in the name of democracy and freedom as
Ahsoka Grieves over the lives of the
Clones that she believes she led to the
slaughter she also deeply questions
whether or not her radically different
training under Anakin Skywalker during
the Clone Wars was forging her into a
force of death and destruction just like
Darth Vader was however the spirit of
Anakin through the world Between Worlds
was trying to get Ahsoka to realize that
while his influence will always be a
part of her that isn't necessarily A Bad
Thing Anakin was trying to teach Ahsoka
that the true root of her fear of
becoming a dark warrior of death was her
misconceptions of the person that she
believed Anakin to be because Anakin
Skywalker was not just the Sith monster
Darth Vader and while yeah it is tough
to just forget about all the atrociously
awful things that he has done while
under the influence of Emperor Palpatine
Anakin Skywalker was always more than
just his Darkest Days In fact when it
mattered most Anakin Skywalker outright
rejected his alter ego Darth Vader to
save his son right before the very end
of his life it's literally the last
thing he did because much like Luke
Skywalker and his mother Padme amadala
firmly believed there was always still
the light of goodness inside of the
darkened outer layer of Anakin Skywalker
and it is that very goodness that this
Cosmic Anakin wanted Ahsoka to embrace
rather than just be ashamed of his dark
side because while it was easy for
Ahsoka to look back at all of her
wartime experiences with Anakin and
perceive him as some type of
bloodthirsty monster who relished in war
that was all simply ahsoka's fear of
Darth Vader clouding her memory of
Anakin Skywalker through these Visions
this Cosmic Anakin Skywalker was trying
to remind Ahsoka that she was not taught
by Darth Vader because Ahsoka has
seemingly forgotten that she was part of
a legacy of incredibly special and wise
Jedi Knights and all of their wisdom has
been deeply informative to the person
that Ahsoka is now during their time as
master and Apprentice Anakin passed on a
lot of the knowledge that he learned
from Obi-Wan Kenobi who learned from
Qui-Gon Jinn who learned from a preche
bag Count Dooku who learned from Master
Yoda Master Yoda was like the wisest
Jedi ever in a strange way they're all
part of this weird Jedi family tree and
much like a lot of people in real life
can relate to not wanting to be like an
incredibly shitty parent Ahsoka was
afraid of adopting the undesirable dark
traits that her Jedi Father Figure
Anakin nurtured within her you know kind
of like Luke Skywalker was afraid of
becoming a Darth vader-like person
through nature as Anakin's actual
biological child however though it
looked like Anakin was just this wartime
murder machine one of the most important
lessons that Anakin imparted onto his
Padawan was how to survive and persevere
in order to protect life in an
increasingly darkening Galaxy because
Anakin cared as much about life as
Ahsoka did so much so in fact that his
fear of not being strong enough to
protect other people is exactly what led
him to the dark side but just because he
fell to the dark side that doesn't
necessarily erase all of the good man
that Anakin was or any of his long years
of dedication fighting on behalf of
people who couldn't fight for themselves
because that is the other brighter and
more important half of Anakin Skywalker
by giving Ahsoka the choice between
living and dying Anakin was also trying
to get Ahsoka to confront her own fear
anger and hatred of Darth Vader by
reminding her that it was the goodness
of Anakin Skywalker who taught her how
to protect herself and other people in
fact if you've watched the Clone War
series then you'd know that Ahsoka would
not have survived Order 66 were it not
for Anakin specifically teaching her how
to defend herself against multiple clone
troopers surrounding her in every
direction that is the Legacy that Anakin
wants his Padawan to remember how to
keep on living in order to fight for
living beings when we absolutely need to
by switching his appearance to that of
Darth Vader and engaging her in a
lightsaber battle Anakin was trying to
get Ahsoka to confront her own Inner
Fear anger and hatred towards Anakin's
darker half while also getting to
realize that she's able to defend
herself as a result of Anakin's
teachings and love for her Anakin was
testing Ahsoka to see if all of that
fear would push her into striking his
Darth Vader form down in Anger for all
the hurt he had done to the Galaxy
however much like Luke Skywalker does
during his confrontation with Emperor
Palpatine and Return of the Jedi Ahsoka
throws the lightsaber that she holds up
to Anakin's head away to symbolically
reject her fear anger and hatred towards
him by using Anakin's training to steal
that lightsaber Ahsoka was able to best
Anakin's dark side Darth Vader in battle
proving her resolve to live and survive
however by throwing her lightsaber to
the side and refusing to kill Vader
Ahsoka also proves that she can also
defeat her own Dark Side a dark side
that manifested as her deep fear anger
and hatred for Vader through the power
of the cosmic force in the world Between
Worlds Anakin Skywalker was able to come
back to teach his Padawan the value of
his lightside influence on her life
while also reminding Ahsoka of her own
inner power that has been within her
ever since she was a baby her deep
respect for life Anakin Ahsoka that
although he did teach her how to be a
formidable and deadly weapon it was only
Ahsoka herself that could decide what
she did with that training because much
like Qui-Gon Jin told Anakin in The
Phantom Menace it is your focus that
determines your reality and by the end
of their encounter Ahsoka chooses to
have complete faith in the merciful and
compassionate person that she willingly
chooses to be by acknowledging her own
fear and rejecting its power over her
because confronting fear is the destiny
of a Jedi as Luke Skywalker tells Ry in
episode 9 Ahsoka emerges from the ocean
with an acceptance of the light sides
and dark sides of both herself and her
former master and that new found and
profound realization will undoubtedly
help her shake her own fears and
hesitations with training her own
Padawan Sabine as previous episodes
seemed to strongly imply Ahsoka being
deeply concerned with accidentally
teaching Sabine how to be another angry
Jedi like Anakin became especially after
taking a Peak at sabine's Nightmares and
then seeing how much Sabine tapped into
her anger while she was training
blindfolded as Anakin's nightmares and
angry training with Obi-Wan were
precursors to his own fault to the dark
side however now that Ahsoka has
accepted that Anakin was more than just
Darth Vader she will now be able to
confidently pass down the teachings of
her master to the Next Generation
because her own legacy is not just the
dark parts of her past the good light
Parts matter too and this overall theme
of Darkness and Light being accepted
together as a whole is one of the main
reasons why I believe Ahsoka has two
black and white lightsaber handles
purposely designed after the ying-yang
symbol because Ahsoka was molded by both
both Anakin's light- sided and
dark-sided Natures into becoming a
deadly Peacekeeper but at the end of the
day Ahsoka will always choose life and
the defense of life because that is who
she has always been in her core and this
is what helps Ahsoka become a more
balanced Jedi just like Ahsoka faced
that saber-tooth as a baby without fear
overtaking her Ahsoka did so again as an
adult in Ahsoka episode 5 by fighting an
unmasked Darth Vader and because of this
encounter with her old Master Ahsoka is
now ready to face Balin once again as a
much more confident Warrior as well as
her Padawan Sabine as a much less
hesitant master and her transition to
her white outfit signifies her rebirth
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter and Instagram
or wherever I am on the internet if you
guys want to see me post some weird
but most importantly follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube and click that
notification Bell so that you never miss
another heavy spoilers video again but
yeah thanks again for watching this
video and let me know what you guys
think of this Star Wars episode in the
comment section below love you guys so
much
bye
oh